if the distance between the plane ax
minus 2y plus z equals d and the plane
containing the lines and they give us
two lines here in three dimensions if
that distance is square root of six then
the absolute value of d
is
so let's think about it a little bit
they're talking about the distance
between this plane
between this plane and some plane that
contains these two lines so in order to
talk realistically about distances
between the planes those planes will
have to be parallel because if they're
not parallel if they intersect with each
other the distance is clearly zero and
they're telling us here that the
distance is the square root of six so we
have a situation so that the planes
can't intersect they must be parallel so
you have this plane up here
you have this plane up here we could
call this the equation here is ax minus
2y plus z is equal to d and then you're
going to have another plane that's going
to be parallel to it maybe it looks
something like this
you have the other plane that is
parallel and it's going to contain both
of these lines so maybe it has this line
so this line is in
alternating green maybe this line looks
something like this it's on that blue
plane and then this line
maybe in magenta is also
is also going to be on the blue plane so
how can we figure out the distances well
a good starting point would be to try to
figure out try to figure out the
equation for this blue plane here and
since these planes are parallel this
equation should look very much like this
orange equation at least on the left
hand side it might just have a different
d value and that's because it has the
exact same
inclination and then once we figure out
the equation for this plane over here
then we could actually probably figure
out what a is then we could find some
point then we could find some point on
the blue plane and then use our
knowledge of finding the distance
between points and planes to figure out
the actual distance from any point to
this orange plane so let's figure out
the equation of this blue plane first
and a good place to start is just to try
to figure out two vectors try to figure
out two vectors on this blue plane then
we could take the cross product of those
two vectors to find out a normal to the
blue plane and then use that information
to actually figure out the equation for
the blue plane so let's figure out let's
figure out first some points that sit on
the blue plane so on this green line
right over here you have see if i want
all of these to be equal to zero you'd
have the point x is equal to one y is
equal to z is equal to three so you'd
have the point one
one
two three that definitely sits on the
blue plane let's come up with another
point let's see if i want all of these
to be equal to 1 i could make this if i
want this to evaluate to 2 i would have
the point 3
i would have the point if i want this to
evaluate to 1 i would want 5 minus 2
over three so three
five and then i would want this to be
seven seven minus three over four is
also one so that's another point
actually both of these points sit on
this line right over here one two three
and then three five and seven and then
let's do the same thing for this let's
find two points on this plane actually
we just have to find one point on this
plane because if you have three points
that's enough to figure out two
different vectors vectors that had that
aren't
scalar multiples of each other
which would be enough to figure out the
normal to this plane so let's just
figure out one more point over here and
one more point would be if we want all
of these three to be equal to zero would
be the point two three four
two
three four because this would be zero
zero zero so that's also sitting on the
plane and that sits on the magenta line
right over there so let's use these
three points to figure out two vectors
on the plane that aren't multiples of
each other then we can take their cross
product to actually to actually figure
out a normal a normal vector to the blue
plane so let's say the first vector a
that sits on this plane let's say it's
the difference in the position vectors
that specify these two points and we
know that'll be on the plane
and so that will be 3 minus 1 is 2 i
plus
5 minus 2 is 3 j
plus 7 minus 3 is
is 4k so vector a
vector a is actually going to be is
actually going to sit on this green line
because both of these points are on this
line so it's going to sit on that line
if we put it on the plane or if we were
to start at one of those points it'll
sit on that line and then we could do
another vector and it's essentially
going between a point on the green line
and a point on the purple line but
that's definitely going to be a vector
on our blue plane and let's go between
these two points that looks pretty
straightforward so let's call vector b
let me do another color so we don't
confuse ourselves with that purple
let's call vector
b let's call that let's see two minus
one is i
three minus two is j and then four minus
three that's just one k
so this also
this vector right here is also sitting
on the plane so if i take the cross
product of a and b i am going to get a
vector that is perpendicular to the
plane or a normal vector to the plane so
let's do that so let's find what a cross
b is
a
cross b
is equal to and this is how i find it
easiest i just write i
j
k this is really the definition of the
cross product or i guess one of them and
we write our first vector we have two
three
four and then we have our second vector
which is just one one one and then this
is going to be equal to first we'll look
at the i component so cross that row
that column out three times one minus
one times four so that's just three
minus four so it's negative
i
and then minus we're gonna have the j so
let me write a minus here minus we just
swap
signs we have positive negative positive
so j get rid of that column that row two
times one which is two minus one times
four so that's minus four is negative
two so we could write a negative two
here but the negatives cancel out so it
becomes plus two
j and then finally for the k get rid of
that row that column 2 times 1 is 2
minus 1 times 3 is 2 minus 3 which is
negative 1. so it's negative
k so this right here is a normal vector
this right here is a normal vector
is a normal vector to the plane so if we
want to find the equation the equation
for that plane we've done it multiple
times we just have to take we just have
to take the dot product of that normal
vector
we just have to take the dot product of
that normal vector and any arbitrary any
arbitrary vector on that that's
specified
that we can specify with with an
arbitrary x y and z and we've done this
multiple times in multiple videos if
this is any point x y z that sits on the
plane so this is any point x y z that
sits on a plane then the point
then the vector let me draw the vector
let's say we go to this point right over
here so this vector right over here is
going to be let me draw it the other way
actually
so this vector right over here let's say
we're going between this point
this point and x y z this vector right
here is going to be
x minus 3 i
plus y minus 5 j
plus
z minus 7 k that's what this vector is
it sits on the plane assuming x y and z
sit on the plane so if we take the dot
product of this and the normal vector
that has got to be equal to zero because
it sits on the plane and then we'll have
our equation so let's call so let's take
n dot that over there so n dot
x minus three i
plus y minus five j
plus z minus seven k if any of this is
confusing to you i've gone into a little
bit more depth in previous videos
especially in the linear algebra
playlist where i talk about constructing
the equation of a plane given a point on
the plane and the normal vector and even
how do you con how do you find that
normal vector so you might want to watch
those if you want some review there but
these are going to be equal to zero so
when you take the dot product
and our normal vector is this so we just
take the x term which is negative 1
times this x term right over here so
negative 1 times this is just 3
minus x
and then plus this y component times
this y component so it's 2 times this so
it's plus
2 y
minus 10 and then finally the z
component negative 1 times this so this
is plus
seven
plus seven minus z is equal to zero and
what do we get so we have our negative x
negative x
plus two i
minus z
and then is equal to let's subtract 3
from both sides so if we take it out
there will be minus 3. if we subtract if
we add 10 to both sides
so then you have a plus ten over here
and then we subtract seven from both
sides
this becomes a minus seven so then on
the right hand side negative three plus
ten minus seven that's just going to be
zero
that's just going to be a zero and just
like that
we have
we have the equation
we have the equation for this blue plane
over here the plane that contains that
contains these two lines now remember
what we said at the beginning of the
video these two planes are parallel so
the ratio of the coefficients on the x
terms the y term and the z term has got
to be the same and so this one has a
positive 2 that has a negative 2 this is
a just to simplify it so it looks very
similar to each other let's multiply
this equation right here both sides by
negative 1. and then we're going to get
x minus 2y
plus z is equal to 0. so this is a
completely valid another alternate way
of expressing the same plane and what i
like about this is it looks very similar
to this at least the ratios of the x y's
and z's negative 2 y negative 2 y 1 z
1 z and remember the ratios have to be
the same so here we have a 1 to 1 ratio
between the z coefficient of the z
coefficient the y coefficient of the y
coefficient so it's also going to be for
the x coefficient so here we know if
this is going to be parallel to the blue
plane we know that a has got to be equal
to one so this is x minus two y
plus z
is equal to
is equal to d
so now let's figure out let's figure out
the actual distance let's actually
figure out the actual distance between
these two planes so we can do is we can
take a point on this blue plane and we
have several examples of points on the
blue plane and find the distance between
that point and this plane over here and
actually i just finished doing some
videos on how do you find the distance
between a point and a plane so i'm just
going to use that formula if you want it
to be proved go watch that video it's
actually pretty interesting proof i
think but the distance the distance
between let's say this group this point
one two three and this plane over here
and this plane so this distance right
here is going to be in the direction of
the normal
the distance
is going to be i want to be careful not
using that so i'll write i'll actually
write out the word don't want to
overload variables the distance is going
to be you literally just evaluate you
literally just evaluate this
let me do it this way you you literally
put in this point for the x y and z and
then you subtract the d in the numerator
and we saw that as the formula for
finding the distance so we're going to
be 1
i'm actually using this point right over
here it's going to be 1
1 because we just have 1x which is going
to be 1 minus 2 times 2
1 minus 4 that's 2 times 2
plus 3
minus d well here the d is just d so
we're just going to write minus d just
like that
all of that over
what is essentially the magnitude of the
normal vector and we saw in several
videos that's just the square of the
coefficients on each of these terms
right here and taking this the sum of
those thing the square root so it's
going to be equal to
1 squared
plus negative 2 squared which is 4
plus 1 squared which is 1. so this is
going to simplify to the distance is
equal to
1 minus 4 plus 3 is 0.
so in the numerator we have negative d
all of that over
all of that over the square root of one
plus four plus one so all over the
square root of six
so they say the distance if the distance
between the plane ax minus two y plus z
is equal
between this plane and this plane over
here is square root of six so they're
saying the distance is equal to
is equal to the square root of six
that's what this information right over
here is maybe i should do that in
another color so you this distance right
that's not another color
the distance between the two planes is
going to be the square root of 6 and so
then if we solve for d
multiply both sides of this equation
times the square root of 6 you get 6 is
equal to negative d or d is equal to
d is equal to negative 6. now what they
care about is the absolute value of d or
the absolute distance so that's actually
this would be kind of the signed
distance it kind of specifies whether
we're above or below the plane since
we're below the plane we got a negative
number i just happened to draw it right
if we were above the plane we would get
a positive number
so this distance is negative 6 the
absolute value of it
the absolute value of d which is the
same thing as the absolute value of
negative 6 is
equal to six so and the take any point
any point on this blue plane and you
look for the closest point on the orange
plane and they will be they will be
exactly six apart anyway hopefully you
found that interesting